[Musique]
dans cette soupe à l'oignon il y a au
coup d'oeil dans celle ci également mais
il ya aussi
ceci dit ça peut surprendre mais la base
reste la même
toute cette hargne on sait comment tu
vas camion elle a sauté pour le
canaliser
le chef david ferguson du restaurant gus
s'amuse beaucoup en réinventant à sa
façon la soupe à l'oignon
j'ai utilisé le goût de sud ouest
américain ah ok quand ce petit piquant
c'est ce piment le griot qui donne aussi
un léger goût de fumé
on part avec les oignons crus ou cuits
ont fait caramélisées oui ensuite on va
dégraisser
oui la bière dans ce cas-ci apprécions
faire réduire les agneaux oui pour le
chef d'origine française michelle childs
la version plus traditionnelle lui
rappelle de doux souvenirs
chaque fois que ma mère faisait la soupe
à l'oignon c'était une grande journée
sion veut et on rentrait tout ça à
manger cette soirée là ça c'est sûr et
la faisait comme un roc merlas donc un
fonds de boeuf fond d'eux qu'ils étaient
faits pendant vingt quatre heures après
réduit pendant 4 à 5 heures bravant la
moitié du volume des oignons caramélisés
encore fait à petit feu pendant
longtemps ça on va faire cuire à feu
doux jusqu'à ce que ça devient une
compote
donc ça c'est les oignons caramélisés
sas a appris qu on vient te voir arriver
là ça c'était après 6 heures 6 heures
avec 8,5
j'ai fait vingt kilos d'oignons à la fin
jean laville 2 vraiment ça réduit ça
réduit si on veut bien le faire c'est
pas un plat qu'on peut faire en deux
heures c'est quelque chose qui prend 1
de deux jours à bien
faire une explication est ce que il ya
un type d'union préférable omnium jaune
ça s'appelle un espagnol ça le donne le
plus de sucre dans la recette originale
ont des glaçons vin blanc ici ou
burgundy rhein
on y va évidemment avec une touche plus
anglaise ici magie des glaces avec du
whisky et peu de bière et bien qu'est-ce
qu'on prend pour faire leur espèce de
bouillon c'est de l'eau justement les
halos autre étape cruciale qui demande
aussi du temps le bouille s'est passé de
utilise le fond de veau ah ouais mais
pas ce que je fais avec le jarret de
porc fumé c'est le même fonction un
jarret qu'on va cuire longtemps et qu'on
ait filoche et la viande retourne dans
l'assaut pour aromatiser le bouillon au
burgundy line on utilise plutôt un
fondeur c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
peut faire dans quelques heures nous ont
fait retire les eaux pendant à peu près
une heure une heure et demie après midi
mirepoix donc céleri carottes oignons
pâtes aux tomates ont fait encore
ressentir pendant à peu près une heure
il s'en va faire partir pendant minimum
vingt quatre heures si on a plus de
temps à faire partir pendant deux jours
évidemment pour cette étape
vous pouvez aussi prendre raccourcis et
utiliser un fonds ou un bouillon que
vous avez sous la main
[Musique]
pour la consistance c'est à votre
convenance moi je mets un roux dans la
soupe ou qu'ils soient un peu plus
épaisse rappelez-nous c'est quoi un roux
un groupe donc ces temps pourtant farine
et beurre ont fait fondre le beurre on
ajoute la farine safa une pâte et donc
ça ça va aider à épaissir la soupe mais
c'est pas obligé au moment de servir
donc on met des coups ton après on met
du fromage râpé et deux morceaux de
ancien cheddar les français on parle du
gruyère quelles raisons avez-vous non ça
est en fait sacratini super bien il y a
un goût le guitariste ça donne quand
même comme le cheddar c'est juste
différent ces mêmes jeux d'hier à la
maison les gens il peut faire avec de
fromage qui veut des croûtons maison r
oui et en plus on met pas dans le
bouillon plus il sera absorbée et onze
gardes avec le fromage important en être
jusque sur les rebonds et que l'hiver
est long plus longue jamais faire de la
soupe à l'oignon
selon aussi mais c'est tellement bon
temps quand les secrets des oignons
birman thein petite amertume de la bière
mais les piments à travers sa fille lola
la voix off on la met pas le petit mot
n'est pas trop fort non ses patrons n'en
sait pas plus quand ça josé c'est juste
[Musique]
alors attaquant à l'appétit remercie les
oignons caramélisés avec beaucoup de
douceur
mais surtout il faut pas se dépêcher
faut laisser le temps des saveurs bien
se développer
c'est quoi le prénom de votre mère
katherine catherine bravo catherine où
il lui avait bien montrer à votre fils
[Musique]